zwei tage nach der brutalen hinrichtung
von jasmin b und alexander k ist die
trauer in ganz deutschland groß zwei
tatverdächtige befinden sich aktuell in
untersuchungshaft doch was sind das für
menschen die täter wir sagen es ihnen
hier wird der mutmaßliche
polizistenmörderin
untersuchungshaft geschickt dem 38
jährigen andreas johannes s und seinem
32 jährigen komplizen wird zweifacher
gemeinschaftlicher mord und wilderei
vorgeworfen einer der beiden
tatverdächtigen ist andreas johannes es
ein wild händler aus dem kreis
neunkirchen am montagnachmittag stürmt
daraufhin ein schwer bewaffnetes
spezialeinsatzkommando
der polizei ein wohnhaus im
saarländischen örtchen sulzbach wenig
später fuhren die beamten einen mann ab
der einen blutverschmierten schlachter
kittel trägt auch der zweite
tatverdächtige wird an ort und stelle
festgenommen
mit schwerem gerät
mit schilden mit brecheisen und hamburg
für die tür aufzubrechen
et cetera und
schals maskiert mit sturmgewehren und
die haben hier wohl dir zwei
pathetischen festgenommen
wie aus sicherheitskreisen zu erfahren
ist war der hauptverdächtige andreas
johannes es 20 21 mit einer bäckerei
pleite gegangen er soll jäger gewesen
sein hatte aber wohl seine lizenz
verloren
nach bild -informationen war es unter
anderem wegen fahrerflucht polizei
bekannt und soll mehrere einträge in
seiner polizeiakte haben offenbar auch
wegen illegalen handel mit wildtieren
bei
durchsuchungen verschiedene objekte
wurden etliche waffen sichergestellt in
welchem zusammenhang diese mit der tat
stehen muss aber noch geklärt werden die
beiden mutmaßlichen täter schweigen
bisher zutat
er bis zum vergangenen jahr war der
hauptverdächtige andreas es ihnen habe
einer bäckerei einen besonders guten
eindruck hatte 38 jährige allerdings
schon damals nicht gemacht das berichten
zumindest seine ex mitarbeiterinnen
respektlos aggressiv unmöglich
[Musik]
egozentrisch
andreas gearbeitet als
bäckereifachverkäuferin wie habe ich den
einen drehgriff gesehen er war zu uns
als chef immer sehr unfreundlich sehr
verbal
herablassend er hat uns nie wirklich als
seine frau angesehen sondern eher als
[ __ ] er war vom wesen her auch
immer sehr aufbrausend
[Musik]
wenn er den raum betreten hat was hat
wirklich auch immer schon so dass man
zusammen gezuckt herr angriffspunkt
deshalb
[Musik]
aggressiv gewesen mit dem ich auch noch
dass anwender geraden sind also
eigentlich einfach nur objekte
hier schaffen pkw machen was er wollte
und
nur die arbeit des jahres gehörten
stimmen ansonsten ja
[Musik]
dort
liegen gab